. Let's go to the phone lines at six one seven,
eight three zero 47 50 starting with Tim.
Tim back in January, I guess was the last
time we heard from you and you were, you were
pretty angry from what I have in my notes
when we spoke back in January is, does that
sound right?
[inaudible]
I don't know if I was angry.
I know we're talking back and forth about
healthcare and how it'd be, well, how it was
going to be paid for with $52 trillion per
year.
I don't know how, you know, with even the,
you know, this assistance you provided me,
I don't even know how I would still be paid
for, but you know, regardless, um, I was seeing
that you are doing a bunch of live streams
on the, uh, impeachment hearings and I wanted
to see, you know, what's your takeaway from
what's going on and what do you think the
outcome for Democrats would be?
Positive or negative?
Well, I've got a big story coming out on this
because on the one hand you've had, you know,
there have been some people testifying who
have not really made a big impact, but certainly
Gordon Sunland has made it clear that everybody
knew what was going on.
Rudy Giuliani knew Mike Pompeo knew Mike Pence
knew Donald Trump knew.
Everybody knew about the extortion, bribery,
quid pro quo.
That should be extremely damaging.
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman had very
devastating testimony, but I'll be honest
with you, Tim, I said, if Democrats can't
turn this into something, it will be very
embarrassing because they're monopolizing
dozens of hours of TV time across all networks.
It is even in its most salacious moments,
you've still got to pay really close attention
for hours at a time to understand what went
on.
And I don't know if Democrats are going to
be able to turn this into something
and to add on what you just, um, I think it's
also costing the taxpayers tens of thousands
of dollars to hold these circus hearings to
begin with.
Um, and when it comes to actually breaking
the law, there hasn't been, you know, substantial
evidence of anything.
Um, that's why even you said they don't have
anything.
Well, no I didn't.
I never, I, I certainly never said they don't
have anything.
What I said is that for, so there's a couple
of different things.
These are not criminal proceedings.
Impeachment proceedings are not criminal.
So we can talk about criminal, but that's
actually that, that's a totally separate issue
altogether.
It relates to the justice department.
Two different things.
We don't want to mix them up, but I certainly
never said they don't have anything.
What I said is as devastating as what they
have is, I still am unsure.
I mean I just, I don't see impeachment happening.
Hopefully this will fire people up enough
that they vote Trump out in November of 2020.
That's, that's for me the most likely positive
outcome that I can imagine.
Well isn't the impeachment hearings in and
of itself, high crimes and misdemeanors according,
you know, based on the president's actions.
So that's important to understand about high
crimes.
High crimes means the person doing it.
Not what the crime is.
So there's a lot of misunderstanding about
what, what that even means.
But we're talking again, you can be impeached,
not because you committed a felony, for example,
but because what you did abdicated the, the
morality, you abdicated the role of the president.
You gave up sovereignty to a foreign country.
There are things that may or may not be crimes
that are ever prosecuted.
They can still be impeachable.
So it's important not to confuse criminal
proceedings with impeachment proceedings.
This also relates to due process.
A lot of the conversations happening about
due process seem to misunderstand what kind
of a proceeding this is, but it sounds like
you're watching the streams and that's good.
At least people are paying attention.
Yeah.
I mean, I've been following this pretty closely
and uh, you know, I follow this regularly
and I see that there doesn't seem, there just
seems to be hearsay from what I see on my
end from second hand conversations.
No.
So Gordon son described his own conversations.
Gordon Sunland gave all firsthand testimony.
So, I don't know, maybe you're defining here,
here's, that's a Republican talking point
that there's [inaudible] say, well hold on.
That's a different question that you first
said that there's only hearsay.
I pointed out that there isn't, and now you
say, well, who cares?
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
From the first two proceedings that we had,
there was all hearsay.
Now we're having a phone directly from the
horse's mouth, but that's still not giving
Democrats anything to work with.
As you said previously,
the weather, whether they have some time to
work, I'm agreeing with you in a sense.
But the reason that they may not have anything
to work with is that you have 62% of Trumpist
who said, I don't care what he ever does,
I will never abandon him.
And when you're dealing with people like that,
he could shoot someone on fifth Avenue and
it wouldn't matter.
So I think it's important to distinguish between
there is nothing versus Republicans won't
care.
And that's the situation that we have.
Tim,
well, the transcript is out.
So the entire transcript of the call is out.
The American people have read the trans.
I haven't seen we released that.
I may have just who released the full transcript.
Some released the full transcript.
No, he, that was a 30 minute phone call.
No, hold on.
Trump released a transcript that was about
six or seven minutes of a 30 minute phone
call.
Unless it happened in the last five minutes.
Trump has not released the full transcript.
See, this is the problem.
People seem to be confused.
The full transcript was never so, so you first,
you now you've said the full transcript has
been released.
It hasn't, and now you're just saying there
is nothing.
You're, you're doing circular arguments.
None of them based on fact.
Every fact you assert is wrong and then you
move on to something else.
To him.
The fact is there is no substantial evidence
for impeachment and you know this and you
know what in your bones, like it's not going
to happen and it's going to end up.
If this were Obama, he would've been, if this
were Obama, he would have been impeached.
Who knows when.
All right, Tim, we're going to let you go.
Tim.
I mean, I guess that's just what a Republican
sounds like, or at least someone who's committed
to the narrative that a Trump Trump can do.
No wrong.
I mean, listen, I'll agree with you.
This might not lead to anything but to say
there's no evidence to say Trump.
Really.
Everything that the guy said, I think almost
everything has been demonstrably a debunked.